as americans for the most part white
americans you know all we really hear
is what we see in the media right so
the media has painted islam and the
koran is just this evil book you know
with extremist evil evil tendencies and
that's not the case at all
assalamu alaikum
dear brothers and sisters we are joined
here
with the beautiful couple
masha'allah mr and mrs muslim this is
how you guys know them
we're not going to tell you their hidden
identities their real names that's just
for us
not just i'm just playing but we have
this beautiful couple here they just
reverted recently and we wanted to bring
them on
ask them a whole bunch of questions and
see how the journey's been going in
islam so far
uh before we even get into that
how you guys doing today
good
[Music]
so how long officially has it been now
since you've been a muslim
um
april 7th we took shahada april 7th so
just over a month
so question did you guys do the ramadan
no
no all right that's all right took our
shahadah you know we had no idea we were
right dab smack in the middle of
ramadan
so all of that came to us and uh it was
just too much too much all at once
got you got you so
for those who don't know
including myself because i don't know
i'm very ignorant to this uh forgive me
if if i didn't take the time out to
watch any of the videos that you guys
had prior
but what led you
to islam
um
back in march um
i would say
february and march
um
i've always been a kind of a quick
backstory i've always been a real
rough around the edges type of guy right
like a lot of people i've lived a pretty
rough life and
always been frustrated and and short
fused and whatnot
and
something happened after the first of
this year
um i would tell christy i started
telling her i said you know i'm i'm
starting i started becoming at peace
with a lot of things just i started
having this peaceful feeling in my in my
life for no reason whatsoever
uh even as far as dying i i told her i
said you know i'm cool with it i'm cool
with what's after this
and then
it happened in
in march i would say mid-march
i was laying in bed uh one evening just
random thoughts going through my head
and for no reason whatsoever i just
started thinking of islam
islam and god and allah and something
from that moment on it
i was consumed by it to where the very
next day that's the first thing i did i
started looking at youtube videos and
researching it i immediately started
watching videos from mufti mank and chef
guzman
things like that and
i was i was
i was i mean
i was consumed by it every minute every
day for a good two weeks straight
um just just by a thought that came to
me
and then uh
about two weeks later i went to christie
and i told her you know i've been
watching these videos and things and i
said uh i i need to become muslim
and after showing her some videos for
just what a few hours or so yeah at
first i didn't believe him you know i
thought he was joking
he's a jokester so
and then
about a week after that i about a week
after me telling christy i couldn't take
it anymore this i just couldn't take it
i i called the first masjid that was
near our house i asked him if they could
help us take jahada and and later that
evening that's what we did
yeah we went
that's
together
so before
all right go ahead go ahead it sounds
crazy i i think i don't want people to
think i'm insane but that's exactly how
it happened
no it doesn't sound crazy man because my
own reverb story was
kind of similar you know i was
i had gotten surgery i was sitting in
this room like on the ground right here
next to me
and i was by myself recovering
and i remember like i just felt this
pool to read the quran
and like the way that it came to me when
i was reading the quran like something
just clicked and when it clicked i felt
these like waves going in my body and i
was like oh i i i guess i'm a muslim now
and like now when i think back to that
i'm like
that's insane that's insane that
something like that would have happened
so i don't think it's actually
i don't think it's crazy at all you know
a lot a lot of guys and he was what he
was
yeah
about that is um
we've been together over 25 years
um
ever since i met him
the the night i met him um i i started
praying for him um
had some sort of peace and
[Music]
um
guidance
somewhere along the way i just
i knew him i knew him the minute i met
him i knew him you know i didn't know
him but i did
and
that's one of the
most things i've prayed for my whole
life is
for him to have some sort of peace and
for it to actually
have my prayers been
answered it's it's unbelievable
hold up hold up you guys said i remember
watching the clip my bad i'm taking up
the spotlight here but i'm just so
curious i have so many questions so i
remember the one clip that we saw
you guys said you've been married for 20
20 something years 24 26.
did i get that correct a little over 25
years
masha allah
so and you're saying chrissy you're
saying that when you met him it's as if
you've known him but you didn't actually
know him
exactly um
the the night
sounds crazy but the night the night
that i met him
um
i fell in love with him and ever since
that night i prayed for him
yeah uh every every single
i prayed for him for for the past 25
years
wow
it's that sounds so beautiful because
christie you say that you've been
praying for him to find peace
for so long
and islam
actually the root word means peace
yeah i
it's also
it's just also amazing
you know coming being here and and
just
i always prayed i wasn't exactly sure
uh what i was praying to who i was
praying to you know um
and
ever since uh we took our shahadah and
learning more and more
about everything it's it's where we're
supposed to be
that's beautiful
i would say definitely i tell people now
that
for the first time in my life i know
exactly who i am and i know exactly
where i'm supposed to be wow
[Music]
that's so powerful
powerful even like even myself someone
who was born into a muslim family and it
was muslim and all that even me like i
really came to islam because i found a
youtube video
i you know had been raised upon islam
and told stories of like you know yusuf
at islam peace be upon him and
i never cared for you unfortunately i
was young i was dumb i was naive i went
to high school i actually went to a
catholic school and it took just me
coming across a youtube video talking
about satan and how he came to be and
all of that
for me to actually go down basically the
same path of just watching video after
video after video just like jay did
subhanallah on my journey in that sense
i came across some people like you know
thou who shall not be named but like you
know david wood and like these people
that would attack islam and i didn't
suffer too much because i went and found
the answers islamically from you know
brothers online sisters online that
would talk about it but did you guys
face any kind of question backlash any
moment of you know maybe a road bump
um
you know it's funny
the people that go on
your your youtube page or your tick tock
they people that spend so much time
leaving the nasty comments when you know
that that's time that could be better
spent somewhere else i i don't get it
um but
no it's again we're only a little over a
month into it but
it absolutely feels right
i feel a piece the weight of the world
has been lifted off my shoulders lifted
off my shoulders
as it should be bro as it should be
so jay
did you feel the same thing with christy
when you first met her that she felt
with you
when you're on the spot kind of yes i i
knew something was there
i got you
in retrospect now you know
of
course god had all this planned out from
day one you know absolutely so
she knew it the whole time she knew
she'd been telling me for years i knew
this was going to happen
and i'll always say that god sent her to
help keep me stable
she she's my rock my foundation
see
that reminds me of this i don't know if
it was a hadith or it was just an
interpretation from a scholar but it was
something that said
that um
the souls
before this life like before coming into
this
reality and this dunya
um you know they
they were all together in the past life
and
some actually created bonds before
coming into this life and though
therefore
once these uh souls meet in this life
they have a connection that's
unspeakable that you can't explain it
but it's just there and it's like right
off the rip
so it's crazy that you're saying it like
that and it it's i just saw this
thinking about it today's subhanallah
it's just
it's insane
we have a crazy connection that we don't
even really speak about too much to most
people because they're gonna they're
gonna lock us up for insanity so yeah
i am with my soulmate
jay you know when you mentioned that for
the first time in your life you kind of
feel like you're exactly where you're
supposed to be
i myself feel that too and the question
i have to you now is how has your
relationship with god changed because if
you're finally where you're supposed to
be according to you then
do you still have the same relationship
you do with god do you understand god
more now are there things that you have
changed in your belief well we weren't
very religious to begin with um
we
we both accepted the fact that we knew
prior to this something created all of
this this just didn't magically appear
from nowhere something magnificent had
to create all of this right even if you
don't believe if you're a non-believer
but
um
ever since
ever since taking shahada
it's
i feel like when we go to the masjid
especially that's i i tell everybody to
me that's like a one-on-one line that's
my direct phone line to god
when i'm when i'm at the shop and uh at
the masjid or when we're praying and
um it feels right yes everything about
it feels right i can't say it's
what i have no what i have i can say is
yes my love and my appreciation i i'm
appreciating small things now things
that i used to maybe walk past before
and not not bad an eye yet
my love for my wife is is immensely
more involved than it was before
um and all of that is due to my
connection with god now absolutely he
used to question a lot and he
he doesn't have any questions
i look at things as if at first i was
saying why at 48 years old am i having
these feelings and these thoughts about
turning to god no i i look at it as if
i'm who am i to ask
who am i to ask the creator i'm nobody
so no
yeah there's a there's a level of trust
in allah trust in god that muslims tend
to develop the more they learn about
allah learning that he's all
knowledgeable he's all wise and ways
that we can't even comprehend just puts
that that tawakkul that trust in allah
and subhanallah allah he says in the
quran
those who believe
and whose hearts are content
with the remembrance of god
indeed with the remembrance of god the
hearts find ease the hearts fine
contentment and alhamdulillah we're so
blessed all of us to be muslim to have
that kind of contentment because i've
seen people and i'm sure we've even all
had moments in our lives where we
weren't conscious of god we weren't
thinking of god we weren't perhaps we
weren't even really muslim and i say
that about myself as well perhaps we
weren't even really muslim and we were
just so consumed i think is the word to
describe it so agitated with
life and ourselves and with others and
coming into islam it really is just
peace
so something i'm curious about is is in
this journey because we kind of went
from
not super religious thought about islam
watch videos boom muslim masha allah and
i'm sure it was just that simple but
what was the first thing that really
stood out to you about islam when you
were researching it was there anything
that kind of popped like oh wow i didn't
know that
um
definitely a lot of the misconceptions
you know
um
not not every muslim is an extremist
right they don't all have will ill will
the real intentions
um and and the parts of where we believe
in uh the same prophets that that is
listed in the bible we have a lot of the
same beliefs and and believe in the
bible and things like that i didn't know
i didn't know there was kind of that
that center point where it all kind of
converges upon so to speak yeah that was
something i was i was intrigued by i had
no idea you know as
as americans for the most part white
americans you know all we really hear
is what we see in the media right so
the media has painted islam and the
koran is just this evil book you know
with extremist evil evil tendencies and
that's not the case at all
so you
you said the bible you were you were
christian before no
not so much um when i was when i was a
kid i was baptized lutheran through my
mother's church
and uh that didn't fly well with me i i
didn't care for that at all so i i
bailed on that as soon as i could
too many
too many just
i don't know
so some of those organized religions and
the churches to me it's it's just a it's
a dog and pony show it's just a way for
people to get together and talk about
their new car that they have and their
you know how their their retirements are
going and i just don't think that their
hearts are truly in it a lot of them
yeah
i think
i think anyone in that will
can attest to that you know they can
they can feel that because man i when i
remember i would go to church
every single time that i went to church
it never felt genuine there's always
something was off about it all every
single time when i was a kid when i went
later in life like it it just never
synced never synced
so i'm guessing that once you kind of
dipped out of that you
you went agnostic right like where you
believed there was something but like
you ain't really
you didn't really look further than that
you just kind of live your life right
yeah pretty much that was it yeah
that's crazy man
and it was what like 30 something years
before
or about 40 that
just to get to this point huh yeah yeah
absolutely so you know and i asked him
like max well i wish i wish god could
have came to me sooner in our our life
together here but again who am i to ask
yeah it all happens perfectly you know
um so
you had said that going to the masjid
going to the mosque that was like
that's like the one-on-one connection
so now a question for you praying at
your house
versus praying at the masjid i'm
guessing you would prefer praying at the
masjid yeah
yeah yeah
i feel like
it's beautiful
it is
i feel like not many people catch on to
that because i myself you know i was
praying at home for like most of i think
over a year i was just praying at home
not really praying at the masjid i
remember i met this brother i met allah
bless him but he like encouraged me to
go to the masjid he's like you should go
to the masjid you should pray at least
isha the final prayer in the masjid
and i was like but what's the difference
like i'm
i'm just gonna be praying at a different
location like
and in the quran like allah says that
in reality everywhere is a masjid
because the masjid is just a place of
worship and anywhere you you pray like
you're worshiping allah
and like i didn't i didn't understand it
so i went for myself and i saw how
beautiful it was
it's just something different for me
it's a different feeling and
we're pretty lucky uh one of one of the
imams
that does the um
does the reciting uh his voice is so
beautiful wow
that when we're when we're at the masjid
honestly i find myself spacing out
because of his beautiful voice i get
caught up in his voice and i get a free
focus
muslim community online
and and the people uh
it's funny because
i tell her we tell everybody that 100 of
our masjid is uh bengali we are the only
two white people there and from the
minute we took our shahadah they
welcomed us as brother and sister
immediately it's unbelievable yeah just
the love the love i guess i can't i love
it i can't get enough of it
marshall where where abouts are you guys
located because i'm bengali myself i
don't know any area where it's it's
fully bengali we're we're outside of
detroit michigan oh okay god you got you
okay now and random question about how
many kids do you guys have
uh two that we know of
and and how how have they
i guess gone around the idea of you guys
reverting to islam how have they
approached it
um absolutely amazing
um
our daughter actually
schools us a little bit here and there
um
with with different things she has a
muslim friend our 14 year old daughter
so she was telling us what we're
supposed to do and too yeah yeah
and then our our son
ver he's very supportive as well um
reminds us are you guys going to the
masjid you know um
yeah during ramadan he was our uh 9 40
p.m time clock to make sure we made it
to the masjid on time for final prayer
it's really good to hear that you guys
are all like in this together
and i have a question for you i know
that allah is the best of planners and
alhamdulillah that allah helped you both
reverb but
let's assume that both of you weren't on
this journey at the same time so for
christy it might have taken a little
longer let's see how do you guys see
that panning out how would it be
different
i don't honestly i don't even think
that's an option
i was about to say that makes sense our
connection is
i mean
for us we
our love from day one is
it's just been unbelievable i mean we
were together seven years before we had
our first child
yeah um
we knew it was it was a lifelong
commitment that i'm i'm lucky guys i'm
super i'm blessed and and the marriage
thing uh the commitment the marriage
like
uh it's hard to explain we were
i guess quote unquote married before we
were actually married the community was
there long before
you know we set our vows and you know
made it official on paper
so that the official on paper thing
yes i guess it means something but it
doesn't mean
that much
i guess
it's just a piece of paper yeah
the bond is much more
than just a piece of paper
i was going to say like bro they just so
they just spoke about being soul mates
like i don't think that would even be an
option for them
like oh what if one of them accepted
islam and the other didn't like they're
in sync
so much so that like
the moment one sees one thing like the
other one's probably seeing that same
thing
the woman one feels one thing the other
one's feeling that same thing
you know
our hearts follow each other they do
yeah and it's crazy like
listen i'm very i'm i'm young
and for a long time i didn't believe in
a lot of things like
this was one of them like this whole
soulmate thing i didn't believe in that
but like i'm you know a lot of showing
me more and more and like senior with
y'all and i've seen other people as well
where they said the same thing that
y'all are saying that's what's blowing
my mind then i saw this hadith today or
the the interpretation from the scholar
just
it's all coming together so clearly so
it's just
it's beautiful that's all i'm going to
say
so i had a question that when whenever i
see
wonderful couples like y'all that have
so much love and and such a bond and
commitment over over like decades and
we're living amongst a time where
there's a lot of divorce and just a lot
of like dysfunction in relationships and
marriages so what advice would you guys
have for couples out there and those
that are wanting to get married to have
a successful marriage now you know it is
sad isn't it it's terrible
the sanctity of marriage nobody takes
nobody holds that true anymore they just
don't it's
getting married in divorce is just like
going to the bathroom for some people i
mean i can put it
um i think like it was for us
i really believe that
if you're looking too hard for love if
you're looking for love
you're not going to find it now i think
i think it'll happen when it's supposed
to happen like everything else yeah and
when you do when you do
find a mate take your time too many
people rush into
to marriage and having kids that they
end up they don't even they don't even
know each other yet and they're having
children and things just
take a little time get to know each
other for a while a few years enjoy each
other's company yeah get to know each
other
so aside from y'all being soul mates
which
allows y'all to stay together for such a
long time
what other insight would you give to
people who
you know whether they're about to get
married or whether they are already
married like how can they
prolong the marriage and stay with their
their spouse communication is key
um you really have to communicate with
one another if something's bothering you
you have to address it because if you
just keep it bottled up inside it's it's
not gonna make for a pretty uh just uh
i don't know why so many people uh i
don't that the word i'm looking for they
end up resenting each other yeah even
you know in their marriage and i i don't
know what really brings people to that
point to be so resentful of each other
and where you don't even want to sleep
in the same house as that person that
and of course
infidelity i mean from a male point of
view
just keep your pants on you know it's
okay to stick with one woman it's it's
really okay i promise
interesting
so just communication then
that's education and um
[Music]
sense though
well like
if you guys have uh
different views on things
you need to keep an open mind with your
significant other
uh because you might not agree with what
they're they're talking about but you
have to
you know
be able to look at the big picture and
see what okay what is your what is
your
and of all the crazy ideas and things i
guess i've done over 25 years she's
never judged me she's never talked down
she's always been supportive of me
but she's like you know if you do that
it's probably going to hurt but you know
i let him do it
masha'allah allah and side note honestly
as a man you really need that from your
wife like even if you're doing something
the hard way a lot of women don't
understand that sometimes men will do
something the hard way just because it's
their way and they just want to do it
and uh kind of
nagging because even if it's not nagging
sometimes guys will see it as nagging
it'll it'll you know put put your man in
a bad place for sure but allah this is
what i love about
because it covers everything even you
know your marriage your relationships
even intimacy allah he says that he put
between husband and wife between man and
woman passionate love and
mercy
and a lot of people especially the
beginning stage they'll get the
passionate love part down
but the mercy especially in the later
stages they'll let it go
and that i think is where a lot of
people fail because if you look at
people nowadays they have such high
expectations for other people
but very low expectations for themselves
they'll have it in their head though i
can you know
flop 20 times on them and whatever but
the moment they don't get the you know
uh the dress code right or the moment
they don't you know show up on time the
moment they asked you know to go 50 50
for a day or something it's
the whole world kind of turns over on
them
and they're okay
i know something that we've agreed upon
too
um too many people couples when they get
married
again they overlook the part of where
when you're when you're becoming one
through marriage to us that means
everything
we've never had separate bank accounts
not mined this not heard that
joint bank account everything from day
one you have to be it's it's like i
guess like a poker game you gotta go all
in you have to go all in
or it's not gonna work yeah
no prenup
no no prenup
no premium
i'll get everything if i get divorced
it sounds like y'all don't get divorced
inshallah
that'll never happen
so after becoming new muslims i still
consider it new it's been a few weeks
what are some goals that y'all both have
and i want both of you to answer this
question just goals you know it could be
short-term goals it could be within the
next few months next few years even as
muslims now that you want to accomplish
inshallah
um
i want to read the quran the quran
multiple times
i want to
learn some of the language
be able to speak it and understand more
um
that's that's my my main goal right now
everybody at the masjid and everybody
online says take it slow and
um everybody hit the our brothers at the
masjid here
uh told us stick with uh fatiha start
with that
learn to understand what is being said
because you know up until this point now
we have no idea what the imam is even
saying when we when we're at the masjid
i want to be able to understand what is
being recited yeah how to be able to go
through the motions fluently and
things like that
[Laughter]
i guess i have to at this point so um
the i3 institute it's a i3 institute.ca
the letter i the number three
institute.ca they offer free to our
weekly classes and i think they're
starting up new classes soon they cover
all the basics from
um you know the islamic belief to the
islamic sciences like you know if if
someone comes and says hey you know it's
haram to do that or it's it's sunnah
recommended to do that
they kind of teach how these things are
derived because it's not people just you
know guys with beards making it up it's
we get it from the quran we get it from
the prophet peace be upon him so we go
in depth into that purification of the
self the nephs they have events like um
i think friday night tafsir which is the
explanation of the quran which i was
actually going to recommend you guys
should also listen to to not just
recitations and translations of the
quran but also what we call tafsir which
is explanations because you can have
like five words and then like seven
pages of explaining
how
miraculous those five words are what
they entail what they mean for example
allah says in the quran indeed after
hardship comes ease and he says again
indeed after hardship comes ease back to
back and the the explanation of this
when you look at the linguistics of how
allah says it in arabic
when he says hardship in both statements
he's talking about the same single
hardship when he says ease in each
statement he's actually talking about
two different types of ease so some
scholars say that that's one blessing in
this life one in the afterlife or it's
just two
separate giant blessings of ease for
every one difficulty you go through and
on top of that the difficulty is just
like an average difficulty but the ease
is like a grand amazing amount of ease
so just from the very specific words
allah uses and how he uses them in the
quran you could have such beautiful
explanations where we you know for me i
say after hardship is ease
but in arabic it's so much deeper than
that and that's where the true beauty
and the miracle of the quran lies
that's the i3
i3 institute yeah dot ca
afterwards
for anyone at any level you can begin
with zero and and i think those people
will benefit even more because they're
coming in with a clean slate in a way
yeah
yeah and um not to overload you guys
because that's what tends to happen with
reverts
is everyone you know all the muslims
want to help out they're so like happy
for you and they want to give you
everything that the reaver becomes
overloaded with all this information
like you don't know what you want to do
so we want to keep it simple um in
regards to knowledge
i3 in regards to the core and which
quran are you guys reading right now
uh
it's green
it's green
listen if you guys can
if you guys can there's this queen right
here this is um
i know romney has one but in my opinion
i i've been reading this one this is my
third time going through the quran the
clear quran i will send you guys
a copy of this as well inshallah if you
guys
send me
your location and your last name
the koran english meanings
yes i've never read that one so uh yeah
yeah you guys you guys can give us give
us like an address po box and amazon
pick a point near you we'll send it your
way inshallah as a gift and when we talk
about which quran there's only like one
quran because the quran is the word of
allah but we mean like which translation
and sometimes the translation is a
little too complex it's a little too old
english sometimes it's it's it's
misinterpreted a lot of times
unfortunately but many of the good uh
translations from the quran this one um
i think is dr mustafa right for the
clear quran it's been one of the most
simple and eloquent ones so yeah
inshallah will send that your way and
we'll send two copies so you both get
one
yeah it's beautiful because it has um
has footnotes so it really just kind of
like lets you dive deeper into it
um now of course it's not a tough sear
but it
gives you a lot of good information and
then the last thing that i want to throw
in
and inshallah i can get this through
because my phone's about to die so if i
cut out then it is what it is
um but the last thing is that i'm gonna
look
for
a few brothers i know one brother in
particular that teaches arabic he's
teaching me so i can see if he can teach
you brother but for the system to look
for a sister who teaches arabic so she
can teach you inshallah
excellent thank you of course
yeah it's kind of ironic because you
know we just live
30 minutes from away from dearborn
michigan which has the highest number of
muslims in the united states
and after all these years you know yeah
i just thought it was kind of funny
yeah
yeah this it's been
uh well we've i've been telling
everybody at least from my perspective
if if everybody could have the feeling
that i had of of taking shahada
acknowledging god through islam
the world would be a better place yes
you know
that actually reminds me of a beautiful
narration i think it was two companions
of the prophet at least and peace be
upon him where they were sitting
by the side of the ocean
and uh all they had to eat was bread
right so imagine this that all they had
to eat was bread and it was so dry
they said it was so dry they had to dip
it into the ocean to make it edible
and subhanallah in this moment a lot of
us a lot of people would be like man
look at our lives you know i'm a muslim
and i'm suffering like this that's not
what they said they said something very
similar to what you said
they said
if the kings of rome and persia
knew
the contentment and the ease and the
feeling that we have in our heart
they would send armies to come and try
and take it from us
absolutely yes
and it's not
everything about islam so far is
it's straightforward it is just straight
forward as far as i'm concerned as far
as we're concerned yeah you
have that connection with god
people
everybody just just like we talked about
a little bit ago nobody stops and smells
the roses anymore you know that old
saying
just stop for a minute everybody in the
world just stop for a minute and just
take a minute to acknowledge god
and and through islam and i i mean do it
through islam not through
any other religion because i don't think
that's the right way to do it but yeah
it's
your heart do your heart a favor do your
heart the favor
you won't regret it
yeah it's about a lot
go ahead bro
oh i'm sorry man i have to slip this in
because it's so beautiful because
everything the brother is saying and
everything the sister is saying is just
like it's
bringing quran
you know ayat verses
in my head allah actually says in the
quran that allah intends for you is not
hardship
and that's literally that is what islam
is supposed to be something that is
simple straightforward do this don't do
that believe this don't believe that and
basically if enjoying good and forbid
evil
again he says that he intends to
um grant you easy he intends for you
ease and not hardship and that all every
soul will only be charged that which is
in its capacity you know there's a
saying also in the quran
you can live for enough
that allah does not burden the soul
beyond that which they can take that
allah is not going to give someone too
much that they can't handle and that
they're going to break
and allah again intends for them ease
and i just well i find it so beautiful
everything that that they're saying is
just
oh this man cut out oh we lost him
it's very it resonates well that's
beautiful
mm-hmm let me just change the angle
all right
yeah um
bro we've we've had so many podcasts
with with guests in the last couple of
months alhamdulillah but i've never had
one where it's it's only been like about
30 minutes and i already feel like i
learned so much and i connected with the
mashallah yeah and you know being being
in the west you know growing up in
canada just like rami i know you guys
grew up in in the states
it it really begs the question why the
media really portrays islam in a way
where it kind of demonizes it and makes
people almost scared to like look into
it almost like just it's a write-off you
know off the bat it's not even something
i'm going to consider because i feel
like it's not too far-fetched to think
that for the society to just have this
power hierarchy and just keep us
enslaved and keep us in the shackles of
the dunya and not have us free and not
have us learn our identities that they
have to kind of do that with islam
because with islam there's no interest
there's no there's no this financial
system where money goes from the poor to
the rich to keep the poor even poorer
and to keep the rich even richer there's
no dysfunction there's there's a family
unit there's respect there's love
there's charity and and
kind of doesn't want that because if
that's the case then everyone's going to
have more and if everyone has more
there's not going to be what you have
today in society so
you're right that's it it is quickly
written off
and it's too bad um because with islam
um coming from two white americans there
there is no ulterior motive to it at all
it's one thing it's about worshipping
worshiping the creator
the only one worthy of worship yeah um
and you're right the
people and we didn't know we didn't i
had no idea until we looked into it and
um giving a certain percentage of your
your
income every every year right towards
charity it's a 2.5 percent something
like that and
islam does wonderful things it is
it is a community it is
i i've never we've never been involved
with such great amazing people
yeah and and the 2.5
and i learned this from brother rami the
other day it's it's not in islam the 2.5
isn't of your of your total income like
we have income tax in you know from the
irs is 2.5 percent of your excessive
wealth yeah right so so it's in and if
everyone just gave 2.5 that's nothing so
it's like if you have forty thousand
dollars you make in a year of just and
you're living good that's like 1 000. if
it's 2.5
and if everyone did that everyone would
have enough to eat everyone could have
food on the table everything would be
cool but yet today in society the way
taxes are and by the way i don't promote
anyone to stop paying taxes that's not
what we're saying we're just comparing
the western financial system to the
sharia financial system and in islam the
financial system we have is so that
everyone eats there's no income tax
where you just give money even if you're
poor and the more money you make the
more money you pay taxes which kind of
makes no sense
and there's a lot of differences that
you found but my question to you now is
what was one of the most fascinating
differences um between i guess the way
of life in the west versus the islamic
commandments it could be anything in the
financial system it could be anything in
terms of
dress code anything that was
particularly noteworthy to you guys
at least for me i i'm i keep going back
to the the sense of community
the fellowship the brothers and sisters
and how
their their desire to
to be charitable to help those less
fortunate than them and sincerely mean
it they sincerely mean it that's that's
one of the biggest things i was blown
away by mine is the love the love the
love that
you feel
it's just amazing i've always been
um nobody's excluded nobody's excluded
from the love i've always wanted
happiness for people and
and i'm i'm now in a place where that's
what everybody else wants and it just
just amazes me it's it's amazing if you
need a ride to major they will pick you
up and bring you there and back i mean
it's
that's that's that's the amazing part
for me
yeah i've noticed that myself as a born
muslim too that we really do take the
community aspect seriously and just like
chrissy said the love that you feel it's
the love the true divine love from
the source the creator the one true god
there's no intermediary there's no
intercessor there's no you have to go
pay this at this place or you have to
sign up for a membership here or
anything like that um it's true it's
real it's the only love that we have the
only unconditional love there is
subhanallah and you know the
relationship we have with allah it's
never gonna go away so if your
relationship is suffering with god you
gotta ask yourself who really changed
it's not allah it's definitely us
but with that being said um before we
move further do you guys have any
questions for us because i know as new
muslims and reverts there might be a lot
on your plate and a lot on your mind me
and rami we're not scholars by any means
but inshallah if we do have you know the
capability to point you in the right
direction we we want to take that
opportunity
um you know nothing off the top of my
head we have
the online community the online muslim
community has been unbelievable
[Music]
support
anything we need to know we we seem to
get the answer immediately yeah it's
amazing the sisters uh one of the
sisters in california had sent christie
a handful of hijabs for her to wear
that's one of the ones she's wearing
right now and
it's yeah
you get the answer
masha allah
that's so beautiful subhanallah and um
you know people might wonder why do
muslims have this kind of bond why do
muslims have this sense of brotherhood
sisterhood this you know fellowship as
you as you explained it to be
and um it's the answer is all over islam
to be honest it's all over the quran all
over the hadith and it's in the actions
in the character of the prophet peace be
upon him and the actions the character
of the sahabah may allah be pleased with
them when you have narrations of the
prophet who you know we love more than
ourselves peace be upon him and when you
get to learn his his story
honestly you guys will probably feel the
same thing or you begin to love him even
more than yourself
because the seerah the story of the
prophet's poems truly is heart touching
and beautiful and
i was i think 17 16 listening to you
know videos lectures on it and when it
got to the point where he you know they
talked about how he passed away i was
just
crying so much but to bring it bring it
back to the point the prophecies upon
him he said
that none of you will be true believers
all right you will not be a true
believer until you love for your brother
what you love for yourself
and when you have a prophet who you love
dearly that instructs you to love for
your brother what you love for yourself
and to to give because it doesn't
decrease wealth and to always you know
be there for your brothers and that the
ummah the nation the muslim nation is
one body such that
when one
you know one part of the body is in pain
the whole body reacts the whole body
feels that was actually what the prophet
said peace be upon him
you know all you're going to get is love
and compassion and brotherhood and
sisterhood in islam and that's something
that i think alhamdulillah most muslims
if they're
in in a community where there are
muslims will feel that and they will get
that response and i did want to ask how
the the online response was because
there are two people that that are
obsessed with islam people who love it
and people who hate it you know but
they're both obsessed and they're both
gonna say what they gotta say so um
how's the uh the general reaction of the
muslims and maybe some of the
non-muslims
well you get your your
um
obviously you get your your little david
wood comments now and then you know
but
honestly it's like 99
supportive and love it's you guys need
anything any questions any of this
whatever
99.9 love yep
that's beautiful
i uh i wanted to ask uh christy about
the hijab
you find a lot of younger girls nowadays
they complain that you know i can't put
the hijab on because you know
whatever reason they just it's just hard
for them
so being a muslim for just over a month
and wearing the hijab and everything
masha allah how was that process for you
was there any difficulty in it or was it
something that you found to be easy
um
sometimes you know wrapping it the right
way is
is a little difficult but actually just
putting it on and wearing it
um i love it
feels natural
i have no issue with it whatsoever
so yeah i don't i don't see why
anybody wouldn't want to actually it's
it's it's a beautiful thing
yes i've had a lot
i saw a lot of people online have said
uh that she looks like she's been
wearing a heat job her whole life
and uh before i give it back to
jay did you have the beard going before
islam or
yeah oh yeah oh i've cut a lot of crap
over it
because i had the middle part shaved out
you know and oh i haven't heard the end
of it
yeah
i was not going to mention that i
promise
that's good yeah muslims um they're
they're they are very loving but they
are very very
um serious about their deen so
unfortunately you'll have some people
that kind of attack
but fortunately you have people that
just advise and something about muslims
as some people like andrew tate will
acknowledge that islam is like the last
stronghold for conservative views islam
is the last stronghold for actually
having your own freaking opinion these
days um the muslims just won't give out
so you'll you'll get the muslims that
are like you know you need to do this
you need to do that
and uh so on and so forth but i hope
that she'll point out you know but i
want to say bro just to add to this
point it's always coming out of a place
of love and it eventually it's it's
something you do get used to because you
see that everyone's coming with a good
intention in mind in their heart for you
right because the if just thinking about
it you guys started a youtube channel
what like a month or two ago and the
support has been crazy but it's like no
one says hey we want to help you but you
have to do this you have to send us this
money or you have to paypal this or
anything it's like people people
generally would not go to like these
extents and lengths that i see people in
the ummah they go to if they really
didn't believe in what they're preaching
wrong because when when you see this in
in some organized religions they always
expect something in return or they
expect some type there's there's some
ulterior motive and with muslims i've
never experienced that and there is none
because at the end of the day we are
looking for the pleasure of allah and
and the badaka the blessings you know
we're not looking for just you know
making a quick you know chump change
today or just getting social validation
or just getting followers or anything
like that it's far from that
yeah
yeah it's pretty wild isn't it you've
seen
that channel that we started just insane
that's not something we expected we just
expected to share our journey
because again i i
my whole thought was if i could get
somebody else to feel that feeling of
peace that i finally have for me that it
was worth it yeah but the amount of
people that are on the channel and the
views and the interactions
uh we've been talking about this the
past few days that honestly is as far as
the position that god has us in right
now
and the way we're
interacting with other muslims we
his channel the american muslim convert
him in maliki i talked to those two guys
and uh
it's
we're using this time now on this
platform to
she gets we get so many comments about
how beautiful we are as a couple and how
we've inspired people and things and i'm
like us just being ourselves
but you know what it's whatever it's
what god wants us to do right now and
and if it helps make somebody's day a
little bit better and maybe makes them
stop for a minute to think oh i want to
make sure i get my prayer and so on so
forth and then we're doing the right
thing
we had brother maliki click
we haven't had a haroon uh yet but
inshallah a lot of people have been you
know really spamming our dm's requesting
brother uh harun so inshallah we'll
facilitate that in the in the next few
weeks inshaallah um but one thing that i
wanted to note on which you mentioned
right now that you just wanted to post
your your video with the intention of
even helping one soul
get kind of the inside that you had with
that intention and that's kind of what
me rami and brother angel whose battery
died um he we started this just with
that intention in mind just to help one
person and the thing is we didn't expect
we'd get where we are today just like
y'all but the reality is one thing that
truly always helps us keep going and
grounds us is
renewing our intentions and always
wondering why we started remembering why
we started because too many people get
caught up in the likes and the comments
and then they
they change the the way they move
what they say they change the videos
they make just to please the algorithm
just to get more likes or get more views
and it's often times that our judgment
and our intention gets cloudy at those
times so it's a reminder to ourselves
first and foremost that
anyone that's an influencer with youtube
with tick-tock understand why you
started and just keep that intention in
mind
yeah that's why even now i'm not
we don't want to just drop a video for
the sake of dropping a video if it
doesn't have any kind of a positive
message or a feel-good vibe or anything
like that then
i don't we don't want it on there no
yeah yeah a lot you know it's it's it's
amazing you mentioned that because this
whole this whole episode i've been i've
been thinking like you know people
people have their shows where they want
like an adrenaline adrenaline spike they
will have their movies like horror
movies where they just want to feel
scared or people have also their feel
good movies their feel good shows
something they just watched to feel good
and i've had my adrenaline spiking
episodes and
all that stuff with the podcast but this
episode has definitely been a feel-good
episode like i have just felt like i'm
chilling on the couch at home honestly
that's what we're doing that's it
you guys are you guys are welcome on our
podcast anytime i think we're
soon to wrapping this up it was it was a
pleasure rami do you have anything else
you want to say uh honestly no i think
we should give the floor to uh mr and
mrs muslim if you guys have any final
remarks
any any final words
um
to anybody that's non-muslim
just just look into it look into it take
a moment you will be you will be
pleasantly surprised
definitely
masha allah very beautifully
foreign